hi it's me Jenny Nicholson I'm the
Millennium Falcon the show millennial
Falcon when you see on the other channel
and now we're on this channel on this
show we usually talk about Disney and
Star Wars and they were at d23 which is
a Disney convention so that includes
Star Wars
I brought Mike Karl sauce because I
heard that people like him I don't know
I've never met him before
hi Mike hey what's up I have two Mike's
now really because I have a mic here and
a mic here so it's like a lot of whimsy
going on here
[Music]
[Applause]
so today we're going to find out news
and I guess look at some things and
Mike's here but he's going to follow me
around here we're in line to go to Star
Wars land it's right back here behind us
are you excited to go we're actually
going to see the model of Star Wars land
it's not actually the real storm the
land is back there we're going to ride
both of the e-ticket attractions and eat
all the exclusive food I'm so excited
I'm gonna get a hat get a souvenir hat
[Music]
so Star Wars land what do you think it's
going to be maybe the greatest thing in
our lifetimes of like seeing like it's
amazing it's like anything you would
want if you're a little nerd boy or girl
or just a human person I was a bit
disappointed it was just a model of Star
Wars land but it still was like 5 acres
big and it was very big first of all my
number one thing is that I want to eat
meat that's sold by an alien there's a
picture in there it's got an alien who
sells meat and I long for handing him
some earth dollars in him giving me a
piece of alien meat that's probably just
a hamburger but then I take it and I
bite and I pretend it's from some alien
world I like that we saw one of the
attraction vehicles and then how to draw
it on the front and evil-looking like
our 5 droid and it wasn't just c-3po it
was just a new droid so we heard about
two rides that we think are coming one
of them is a simulator type right where
you're piloting the Millennium Falcon
there's different options for endings so
I think it's kind of the new Star Tours
and you want to take the other one
yeah the rumor is it's an escape from a
prison like you're in an empire or first
order of prison and you're in a little
vehicle and we saw the ride vehicle and
you're being escorted but something
breaks you out we're not sure the story
yet and we also heard that the big
Millennium Falcon is a walkthrough and
that you enter the Millennium Falcon
ride by walking through the scale model
of the Millennium Falcon like in most
conventions at d23 it's really about
showing that you're the biggest fan
out of everybody here
people like to dress is the most
specific Disney things they can think of
so I'm going to go try to find the most
niche cosplays that I can hey look it's
the gammas and max from an extremely
goofy movie that's pretty niche whoa
it's one of the parade's support dancers
for the princess unit for the
soundsational parade
that's pretty niche oh my gosh are you
dressed as mega doc from Darkwing Duck
yes I am well that's pretty niche are
you dressed as Ariel specifically from
return to the sea The Little Mermaid -
yes I am okay that's kind of niche so we
just saw the animation panel for Pixar
and Disney all of it what did you think
we've got a lot of stuff in progress you
know like a lot of things you know we're
working on this still and it's not done
don't judge us but we got a lot of clips
from upcoming movies wreck-it Ralph -
Incredibles - plane three well if they
didn't say it was planes but it had
planes with eyeballs in it and it's
planes three this time they go to space
planes three planes in space are you
excited for that I am the planes are now
Jets were there Jets in the first two
planes movies I think so I don't really
know the difference but yes I think so
and they announced an untitled suburban
fantasy movie we had a visual joke where
instead of raccoons and unicorns and
they're pests and they just like knock
over garbage cans and eat the garbage so
I think that could be the best one that
they've announced so far but it seems
like it's so early that it could also
just get canceled and forgotten next
year and we'll never hear about it again
record I'll do it on like an odd sange
and also that what the majority of the
clip they played was like a spin-off
parody of Penelope meeting all the
princesses I guess the princesses live
in the Internet and that's a strong
enough connection to have the most there
in our story vanilla peas game sugar
rush breaks and Ralph and vanellope have
to travel into the internet and find a
replacement part it's the only way to
save the game right absolutely
yeah well they started it out by like
they visited the web
website that I guest appearance from one
of our girls that is cool though to see
a celebrity yeah well they all turn up
to 23 would you like to give a rundown
on the Incredibles to cliff nation yet
they showed a clip of Jack Jack and mr.
incredible mr. incredible at falling
asleep and Jack Jack had gotten out and
couldn't saw a raccoon that was was you
know rummaging in the trash and Jack
Jack has this like pretty brutal fight
with a raccoon and I felt very bad for
the raccoon because the raccoon was like
scared a lot and like it's like thought
it was going to die mr. incredible
realizes that finally the baby has
powers he's very excited about it he
doesn't care about the raccoon I did
like the idea of a super-powered baby
that because it hasn't settled yet it's
just got the potential to have any power
and then I assume it'll have one power
in the end that matches its personality
what did you think of Olaf frozen
adventure this is a 21-minute featurette
that's going to be released in theaters
this November with Pixar's Coco I liked
it Josh GAD came out and he seemed sang
a song from it and then Kristen Bell was
there she didn't sing any songs and then
they said we're making frozen - I think
the crowd was most excited about when
you say Sam Jackson coming on you're
right
the crowd went nuts when sam dekker came
out to be incredible Sam and they're
talking about The Incredibles - Coco I
thought looks like it's gonna be really
good
they came out and they played one of the
songs from it that was really cool that
was the big finale there were dancers
like going up and down the aisles yeah
everybody a very high energy music
number of like a lot of people in the
audience is like mmhmm we didn't know
into a plot okay
yes a certain environment it was a
little awkward
was there anything you expected to see
announced today that didn't get
announced expected maybe a just a crazy
announcement maybe that you were like
wow they're doing this so yeah that's
all yeah I thought they were gonna break
the mold and we were going to get an
animated Star Wars movie just read up
and it's just like the cute Disney
character models that's in the Star Wars
universe and then people will go what
that's the thing you
now you can have the animated Star Wars
movies yes we can and we are that
would've been great but instead there
was a c-3po cameo in wreck-it Ralph so
that is the way that is what happened
it's just in a different slightly
different context
oh my goodness it's Holub screams
chunkies oh hey it's Jenny from the
Millennial Falcon weekly commercial
actor Mike Carlson I hired him to hang
out with me today that's pretty cool how
you like Indy 23 okay what's your
favorite part I I really like kind of
get off on getting recognized and like
the only place that happens is comms
because I go to my dead-end nine-to-five
job come home to a wife who hates me
children who look at me with contempt
drink myself to sleep and then wake up
and do it all over again
sounds great hell
hey you guys are pretty stereotypically
Disney okay crucified all right let's be
a thumbnail get in here we're going to
make a thumbnail guys be 23 yeah so
we've got a live-action panel today Mike
yes we did that right it is right yes it
is that's my name in what's correct well
let's go in order firstly we had wrinkle
in time the time travel adventure about
a girl and her father
Oprah was there that was very exciting
she did her whole bit like you get
opposed to you guess she did the whole
thing like blood Zeppelin playing
stairway to heaven it's like what you
know what's her thing that's known for
can be moved on to Nutcracker magic of
the four realms I believe was and the
fluoro
doctor in the for realm uh yeah so bad
you guys it looked so bad it's like
imagine if Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland wasn't made by a man you'd
heard up and wasn't about a thing you
were familiar with I want to apologize
to the makers of Nutcracker in the four
realms or what Jenny is saying I'd like
to say that I'm open-minded and
open-hearted about their upcoming film
they couldn't pay me the seen Nutcracker
in the four realms Lion King they saw a
lion kill a little bit of Lion King yep
looks just like the Jungle Book
but I'd like to go five minutes and it
was basically a shot-for-shot recreation
of the cartoon Lion King but it's not
cartoon it's animals and that's okay
like Rafiki he rubs the powder on Simba
Simba sneezes and it's so cute yep and
then he holds it up into the song play
never like apologize which is a bit
weird he's like I'm sorry guys and
movies take time it's a lot of work it
was awkward it was like your dad telling
you he couldn't get you what you wanted
for Christmas we heard Aladdin is coming
we saw a brief thing about Dumbo Tim
Burton was in a little choo-choo train
and he said hey and he said hey guys I'm
very busy I'm so sorry and then he
tooted the train whistle you know what
in many wheeled away a lot of people
were sorry today people apologize so
weird vibe for this for the thing I
think I've run into any war they brought
out not every single Avenger but they
brought them out one at a time to make
it seem like more of them than it was it
was a lot number it was like a dozen
dozen events they also have these big
statue things of analysis children
they're his little kids Oh Mary Poppins
alright probably the most excited for
Mary Poppins you saw that Mary Poppins
is singing and falling into a bathtub
you saw that she's singing to 2d
animated things just like an original
Mary Poppins it's like glass popping
stuff no he had Lucasfilm and they only
had a behind the scenes real they didn't
apologize but they were the ones that
most should have apologized because I
felt like we didn't see that much from
them I would have liked an apology
behind the scenes real could we glean
anything from that to do what did you
glean well I did finally because in the
first teaser we didn't see many new
aliens and there were a lot of little
brief alien which I liked we're stall
yes nice old tiny guys there was a
little glimpse of this casino planet
that's very rumored yeah and you can see
a little kid I guess in Star Wars
universe children can gamble in casino
yes I hope that's true or at least stay
in them if it's a casino hotel worn out
like children in this you're right that
could be a shorty Lee that I'm very
racist and then they moved on to the Han
Solo movie and they said remember the
Han Solo movies we're still making it
they brought out no cast members they
showed a picture of all the cast and
we're like yeah we know they showed no
clips and they said Kathleen Kennedy
isn't here because she's hiding in
London trying to fix things I didn't
feel quite concerned about the Han Solo
movie but I feel like there was enough
dazzle in that to distract people enough
so maybe maybe I'm the only one I'm
going to ask people and find out
you are not welcome to join me wait here
oh do you think this convention had
enough going that you're sufficiently
distracted from the huge burning trash
pile that is the Han Solo movie
I'm officially distracted until I see
one more set photo of something that I
don't like then I will be restricting
okay did you see anything you were
dazzled by that distracted you from
horrible wreck of the Han Solo movie the
Star Wars diorama we looked at that
really big model of Star Wars land which
isn't called Star Wars land but we're
all just going to call it that let's be
honest yeah that's a great distraction
yeah yeah there's actually been a lot to
distract me from the turmoil consuming
this film the infinity Wars trailer was
so good it makes me completely forget
about Han Solo in the need for it
honestly the animation panels probably
would absolutely the most sets pretty
good destruction from the Han Solo movie
and I actually forgot until this moment
that it was rumored that Ewan McGregor
was at Disneyland yesterday and today so
everyone thought they were going to
announce Oh be on movie but they didn't
they didn't totally didn't I'm not even
disappointed they saw so much yeah
there's so much happening here
well that's time for your segment Mike
good yeah I have a really great segment
plan for you it's a really funny bit
that's great I'm so excited now okay
ready
so Jenny told me that my segment is I
have to go buy her some chips from the
snack stand over there
although now that I think about it she
didn't really tell me which chips so I
feel like I'm gonna go classic Lay's
yeah
I've got a lot of different types of
sodas these days
Wow thanks for joining us everybody been
a great d23 I did so much her chips oh
oh yeah I forgot
enjoy them I had pizza I think I'm good
Marty's open okay well next week we're
going to be covering Comic Con so they
told me to tell you to watch that do it
or I'll get in trouble
nah no thanks to Mike Carlson I don't
already win did he seem mad to you guys
I didn't ask him to do that much I
thought it was a pretty simple request
tune in next time bye bye bye